ces derniers jours tous les regards sont
tournés vers lui astrazeneca doit rendre
des comptes
le vaccin du groupe pharmaceutique qui
pourrait être le troisième être approuvé
au sein de l'union européenne a été
recommandée au moins de 65 ans
uniquement par la commission de
vaccination allemande
mais le laboratoire dément et affirme
qu'il est aussi efficace pour les
personnes de cette tranche d'âge lui a
commandé 300 millions de doses du vaccin
avec une option d'achat de 100 millions
supplémentaires
mais un autre problème existe toujours
astrazeneca annoncé une baisse de 60 %
des livraisons attendues
un retard qui serait due d'après la
firme a des soucis de rendement dans sa
chaîne de production européenne de son
côté bruxelles s'impatiente
l'europe a investi des milliards pour
développer les premiers vaccins et créer
un véritable come un mondial maintenant
les entreprises doivent tenir leurs
promesses pour sa part failli leur
biotech promet plus de 100 millions de
doses pour le d'ici fin 2021 après une
première commande de 400 millions en
france plus d'un million de doses de ce
vaccin ont été injectés moderna est
encore loin derrière seulement cinquante
mille premières doses ont été transférés
sur le territoire français premier né
dans la grande course au vaccin le
spoutnik v produit en russie et l'ue est
encore quasiment absents sur le vieux
continent
une situation qui pourrait toutefois
évoluer si l' agence européenne de
médicaments venait à valider son dossier
vladimir poutine se montre confiant je
dirais que nous avons de grands projets
au cours de cette campagne de
vaccination contre la grippe
presque 70 millions de personnes se sont
fait vacciner comme anna popova
m'informer hier il s'agit de 68 millions
de personnes dans la lutte contre le
coronavirus nous devons atteindre plus
ou moins le même niveau
reste à savoir si les vaccins français
ont encore un rôle à jouer
l'union européenne a notamment pré
commandé 300 millions de doses à la
firme sanofi
malgré l'arrêt de son principal projet
l'institut pasteur à lui engagé ses
recherches sur deux autres candidats
vaccins